qué tan real es una escalada bélica
entre china y taiwán y sobre todo qué
tan realista es el plazo de taipei que
advierte sobre una invasión a gran
escala para 2025 qué tal buenas noches
mira yo te recuerdo la historia y desde
una perspectiva de largo plazo la
historia de la creación de taiwán desde
1949 es altamente conflictiva y
particularmente desde los 70 siguen el
siglo 21 el gran cambio ha sido la
enorme presencia china en todos los
ámbitos incluyendo el militar entonces
hoy en día depende yo te diría
prácticamente de la garantía militar y
de la alianza militar que tiene con eeuu
entonces es una relación triangular muy
sui generis en donde no se espera una
intervención militar por parte de china
pero hay una cantidad de misiles barcos
y otros instrumentos militares en donde
china insiste en la política de una de
una china y donde china la la república
popular china considera a taiwán parte
de esta única china
doctor 2 el cual podría ser la respuesta
de eeuu si llegase a presentarse el
escenario bélico estaría dispuesto a
entrar en disputa con china
pues es la pregunta del millón no como
dicen
mira al día de hoy yo te iría pareciera
que todo indica que china
no está interesada en una disputa
militar y no necesariamente con taiwán
en donde hay un poderío militar y
económico muy superior de china con
respecto a taiwán no está interesado en
una disputa abierta con eeuu eeuu así
pareciera ser al día de hoy y
garantiza que la soberanía de taiwán a
través de esta alianza militar no
pareciera haber un escenario al menos en
el corto plazo de una abierta disputa
militar entre las dos mayores potencias
y economías del mundo
y finalmente hace parte de esta amenaza
de los movimientos que está haciendo
estados unidos hacia esa región por
ejemplo alianzas como el acuso el quad
claro
lo que tú señalas es de la mayor
relevancia y una diferencia importante
de la administración baiden actual con
respecto a la administración trans es
decir buscar alianzas en el lindo
pacífico con australia japón y otros
países esto todavía no ha sido explícito
en américa latina pero pudiéramos
imaginarnos que también buscará la
administración bailén
hacer una frontera una barrera anti
china en américa latina es una nueva
estrategia de la administración brain
baiden y tendremos que ver las
reacciones por parte de la república
popular china